all right you may or may not remember
the story I'm about to talk about this
incident uh in question happened in
September of 2020. there was an incident
where there was BLM antifa Joe Biden
spray painted at a business and all of
the right-wing media even though the
entire thing stung to high heaven came
out to talk about how violent the left
is and how terrible and venteroristic
black lives matter and antifa are and we
have now learned from court documents
and a release from the District of
Minnesota district attorney of
Minnesota's office that it was all a
hoax it was all an insurance hoax so
let's start with the new document from
the U.S attorney's office from Minnesota
Brooklyn Center man pleads guilty to
insurance fraud after staging a
politically motivated arson attack uh oh
that's pretty interesting what happened
um according to court documents on
September 23rd of 2020 Dennis Mala 30
years old falsely reported to law
enforcement that someone lit his camper
on fire oh it was a camper not a uh yeah
not a business a lid is camper on fire
and that three unknown males were near
the home when he heard an explosion Mala
also reported his garage door was
vandalized with spray-painted graffiti
which said Biden 2020
BLM and an antifa symbol and that his
camper was targeted because it had a
trump 2020 flag on it the idea was this
was a political
incident in reality Mala started his own
property on fire and spray painted the
graffiti on his own garage according to
court documents Mala submitted multiple
insurance claims seeking coverage for
the damage to his garage camper vehicles
and residents when the company denied
the claims he submitted a complaint
Mala also created and allowed others to
create multiple GoFundMe accounts to
benefit him and his family he submitted
more than three hundred thousand dollars
in fraudulent insurance claims got 61k
from his insurance company and 17 000
from donors via GoFundMe
he has now pleaded guilty to one count
of wire fraud sentencing will happen at
a later time
so how did we find out this was a hoax
well as it says in the release it was
investigated by the FBI and the Brooklyn
Center remember this Brooklyn Minnesota
Brooklyn Center Police Department
let's go back and look at how Ben
Shapiro and uh Laura Ingram talked about
this particular incident at the time
there's a story out of Minnesota
that began to get some traction today
and it was very disturbing
um and this was a uh a homeowners who
woke up to find that their garage
basically was on fire did they really
burn down they had a trump they had a
trump uh you know flag or poster up and
had been burned and then Biden 2020
uh graffiti and the antifa symbol uh and
this this is Minnesota nice there's a
message being sent Ben by the far left
and I think people are beginning to see
that arsonist's behavior looting even
murder none of it's off the table right
well the fact is by the way murder what
are you talking about generic statements
about violence and looting being bad are
not going to cut it we all know that if
this were right Wingers who were
performing this kind of violence Joe
Biden would be out there on the front
lines proclaiming that right-wing
ideology was innately linked to violence
and cruelty but as soon as it is left
Wingers in his Coalition who are out
there harassing people at restaurants or
burning things down or perhaps shooting
police officers as we saw in Louisville
last night well then the movement that
they are linked to the broader
ideological movement they are linked to
he refuses to condemn it's one thing to
condemn generically violence and looting
I was told by the way when Donald Trump
did that back in Charlottesville that
wasn't enough he had to specifically
condemn one specific ideology which by
the way he kind of he absolutely did
actually yeah
so it was all a hoax and the of course
none of them are following up on it it
was actually an insurance hoax
perpetrated by an actual trumpist
because remember even though the BLM
Biden antifa stuff was fake in the sense
that it was done by the homeowner the
homeowner's Trump flag was real it was
really a trumpist homeowner now does
that mean all trumpists are Insurance
fraudsters of course it doesn't but look
at how the story was leveraged by Ben
Shapiro and Laura Ingram to make a
broader point in general leftists are
violent antifa is violent black lives
matter is violent and they are willing
to go even further using the fraudulent
and fake story of the spray paint
to say even murder isn't too much for
them well what do you what murder what
are you talking about what on Earth are
you talking about the real scary part is
that when the the Fox News audience sees
this they start to believe well if the
left is so violent against us then we
can be violent against them because it's
only fair even though the premise is a
fraudulent hoax for which someone has
now been convicted so
you'll never get the correction from
them obviously but at least I'm doing
what I can to make sure you know the
entire thing they made a big deal out of
it for multiple days back when it
happened the entire thing was a trumpist
hoax